Follow Langfocus on Facebook, Twitter, and
Instagram.
Hello everyone, welcome to the Langfocus
channel and my name is Paul. Today's
topic is the Celtic languages. Celtic
languages are today spoken mainly in the
British Isles where they've existed
alongside English since the Middle Ages.
The numbers are not exactly clear
because the Celtic languages have gone
through declines and revivals and people
have varying degrees of ability, so take
these numbers with a grain of salt. But
there are around a million speakers of
Celtic languages in total. That includes
Welsh with around 508,000 speakers and
around 310,000 fluent speakers, mainly in
Wales. Then there's Irish Gaelic which
has around 80,000 proficient speakers
who use it outside of school, but around
two million people have at least some
knowledge of it, mainly in Ireland and to
some extent in Northern Ireland. Then
there's Scottish Gaelic which has around
57,000 native speakers and around 87,000
people with some knowledge of the
language, mainly in Scotland. There's also
a small Scottish Gaelic community of
around 2,300 people in Cape Breton in Nova
Scotia, in Canada. Then there's the Breton
language spoken by around 226,000 people
mainly in the Brittany region of France.
That figure of 226,000 includes students
in bilingual schools. Then there's the
Cornish language spoken in Cornwall
which came close to extinction in the
19th century, but has undergone a revival
and now has a few thousand fluent
speakers. And then there's the Manx
language spoken on the Isle of Man which
has only around a hundred native
speakers, and a couple thousand people
who can speak some Manx. Today they're
not spoken by a very large number of
people and they're mostly limited to the
British Isles and Brittany in France
but historically the Celtic languages
were once spoken over a much larger area
than they are today. During the first
millennium BCE they were spoken across
much of Europe from the Iberian
Peninsula all the way over to the Black
Sea and even in part of Asia Minor one
probable proto Celtic culture was the
Urnfield culture of Central Europe in
the late Bronze Age. It was a flourishing
culture from around 1200 BCE. Its
language was at least likely an early
form of Celtic if
not proto-Celtic, and we think so partly
based on place named evidence. Proto-
Celtic developed into various Celtic
languages which were spoken over a wide
area in Europe. The earliest attested
Celtic language is the Lepontic language
the language of the Golasecca culture
that descended from the Urnfield
culture. There are about 140
Lepontic inscriptions that were
discovered in northern Italy and
southern Switzerland. These inscriptions
date from around 550 BCE to 100 BCE the
Golasecca culture had strong
connections with the neighboring
Hallstatt culture, the major Celtic
culture at that time. These languages on
the European mainland and in Asia Minor
are referred to as the Continental
languages.
This is a geographic grouping not a
linguistic one and there are no
particular linguistic innovations that
would make them a linguistic grouping.
Here are some Continental Celtic
languages that might ring a bell.
There's the Gaulish language spoken in
Gaul, within present-day France. And
Galatian, spoken in Asia Minor around
present-day Ankara, Turkey. The
Continental Celtic languages are all
extinct. Celtic speakers began to die out
or become assimilated into the Roman
culture by around 200 BCE. Before the
death and assimilation of Celtic
speakers on the mainland, some Celtic
speakers migrated to the British Isles.
The Celtic languages that developed in
the British Isles are known as the
Insular Celtic languages. The Insular
Celtic languages are still alive today
There are two groups of Insular Celtic
languages: Q-Celtic, or Goedelic, languages
which include Irish, Scottish and Manx
Gaelic, and the P-Celtic, or Brythonic
languages, which include Breton, Cornish,
and Welsh. These two groups of Insular
Celtic languages are not intelligible
with each other, but within each group
there is some degree of intelligibility
depending on the dialects being spoken.
The two groups of Insular Celtic
languages evolved from a common ancestor.
The oldest known Insular Celtic language
is a form of archaic Irish sometimes
called Primitive Irish. It is found in
the Ogham inscriptions from the early
4th century CE. Ogham is an alphabet
that was used to write Irish as it grew
from Primitive Irish into Old Irish and
was used until about the 9th century. Old
Irish eventually developed into the
Modern Irish Gaelic of today. Speakers of
Old Irish also migrated to Scotland
where it eventually
we developed into Scottish Gaelic, and to
the Isle of Man where it evolved into Manx.
While primitive Irish arose in Ireland
Common Brythonic arose in Great
Britain. Common Brythonic is the ancestor
of all the P-Celtic or Brythonic
languages. The Pictish language, which
went extinct by the 12th century CE,
may have been a Brythonic language. But
it's possible that Pictish was related
to Brythonic but not descended from it.
Over the course of a few centuries
Brythonic dialects evolved into Welsh,
Cornish, Breton, and Cumbric, which is
extinct. The Celtic languages were under
great pressure during this time.
Breton is in fact spoken in continental
Europe in the Brittany region of France
even though it's an Insular Celtic
language. It has been spoken there since
the 6th century CE when some Celtic
speakers fled during the Anglo-Saxon
invasion of Britain. Coexistence with
English. Britain was ruled by the Romans
from 43 CE to 410 CE, but after the
departure of the Romans the Anglo-Saxons
began to invade Britain. In Britain the
Anglo-Saxons conquered the Celtic
peoples and either eliminated them or
intermarried with them, depending on the
source you consult, eventually replacing
the Celtic Languages with Old English,
but not in Wales and Cornwall which
remained Celtic. In Scotland Gaelic
speakers from Ireland migrated to the
west coast around the same time that
Anglo-Saxons migrated to the east coast,
then Scottish Gaelic began to develop. In
Scotland Gaelic coexisted with the Old
English dialects that would later
develop into Scots and Scots English
and in the year 1707 Scotland formed a
union with England and Wales: the Kingdom
of Great Britain. After that Scottish
Gaelic began to diminish in use, partly
because English was the language of
universal education. Scottish Gaelic is
today considered definitely endangered
by UNESCO world language project. Wales
came under the control of England in the
year 1282. Welsh has continued to be
spoken until the present day, but for a
long time
English was given preference as the
official language and in the nineteenth
and twentieth centuries Welsh declined
rapidly in favor of English. But efforts
have been made to conserve the Welsh
language and everybody learns at least
some of it in school. And some people
take their entire public school
education in Welsh.
And as I mentioned before it currently
has hundreds of thousands of native
speakers. Cornwall was under English
control by the mid-ninth century. Their
language began to disappear after
England passed the Act of Uniformity in
1558. This was a law that made English
the sole language of church services. The
Cornish language almost became extinct
and it was actually temporarily declared
extinct by UNESCO. But a revival movement
in the 20th century has given new life
to the language and it is now taught in
some schools. And there are now about 300
fluent Cornish speakers. On the Isle of
Man the Manx language is in a similar
situation. It almost became extinct but a
revival movement has resulted in a few
hundred fluent speakers of the language.
There is also a Manx language primary
school they're creating a new generation
of Manx speakers. Ireland became an
English colony from 1169 to 1949 Irish
remained the majority language there
until the 19th century when it was
overtaken by English. Despite strong
intentions to support and revive the
Irish language it continues to decline
in favor of English. It is taught in
schools but not many people use the
language of their own volition outside
of schools. And similar to Scottish
Gaelic it is considered definitely
endangered. The Brittany region became
part of France in the 16th century. In
France there is no official recognition
of any regional languages. The majority
of Breton speakers today are in their
sixties or older and the number of
speakers could be dropping by 10,000 per
year. It is considered severely
endangered by UNESCO. Now let's look at
some features of Celtic languages in
general.
Celtic languages feature VSO word order.
Actually Continental Celtic languages
probably had freer word order, but
let's focus on the living Celtic
languages.
Here's an example of VSO word order in
Irish Gaelic. This sentence means "I saw
the man this morning."
"Chonaic mé an fear ar maidin."
Word-for-word it's see (past tense)-
I-the-man-on-morning. You can see that
it's VSO. Another sentence. This one means
"The man was painting a chair yesterday."
"Bhí an fear ag péinteáil cathaoir inné."
Word-for-word its be (in past tense)-
the-man-(progressive)-paint-chair-
yesterday. You can see that it's VSO with
the auxiliary verb coming in first
position and the main lexical verb
coming after the subject, and then
there's the object. Next, Celtic languages
feature inflected prepositions which are
basically a combination of a preposition
and a personal pronoun. Let's look at an
example from Welsh. The preposition
meaning "on" is "ar" and the stem that comes
before inflections is "arn". So we have
on me - "arnaf", on us -
"arnom", on you (singular) -  "arnat", on you
(plural) - "arnoch", on him - "arno", on her -
"arnyn", on them -
"arni" (note there's an error: "On her" and "on them" are reversed). A similar kind of inflected
preposition exists in Semitic languages
like Hebrew and Arabic. Next, Celtic
languages feature initial consonant
mutations, that is a change in the
continent at the beginning of a word
depending on its context. For example, if
the word is preceded by a definite
article in the genitive case. Let's take
a look at this in Irish. So we have the
word for "man" - "fear", but if we want to say
"of the man" it becomes "an fhir". And it's
similar for the dative case. If we want
to say "to the man"
it becomes "don fhear". do, an, don, don fhear.
It may be hard to hear a difference in that
consonant but there is a sort of
softening of the F sound. In some
dialects that mutated consonant sounds
something like a V sound. In other
dialects it's silent.
Not only consonant mutations but also
vowel mutations occur in Celtic
languages as a morphological device.
Let's look at some examples from Welsh.
Vowel mutations can be used in forming
different parts of speech. "au" becomes "eu"
so the noun "haul" meaning "sun" becomes the
adjective "heulog" meaning "sunny". Vowel
mutations can also be used in the
formation of a plural. "w" becomes "y" so the
singular noun "cwch" meaning "boat" becomes
"cychod" meaning "boats". Celtic languages also
feature and impersonal verb form serving
as a passive or intransitive. An example
from Welsh. "Dysgaf" means "I teach".
"Dysgir" means "is taught" or "one teaches".
This is an impersonal verb that is not
conjugated for person. An example from
Irish: "múinim" - "I teach". "Múintear" - "is taught", "one
teaches". In English there is no specific
verb form dedicated to the passive. You
need to use an auxiliary verb plus the
past participle which has some other
functions as well. Differences between
the P-Celtic languages and the Q-Celtic
languages. These two groups of
languages have had thousands of years to
diverge so there are a lot more
differences between the two branches
then there are between the languages
within them. There are a lot of cognate
words shared between the two groups of
languages but you could say that they
are distant cognates because sound
changes and spelling changes have made
the words unrecognizable in many cases.
The labels P-Celtic and Q-Celtic reflect
the way these two groups developed from
Proto-Celtic. If we look at the cognates
that are shared between both branches, in
the P-Celtic branch there are words that
commonly begin with p or b, while in the
Q-Celtic branch they begin with C or
K or Q. For example the word for "what".
In Irish it's "Cén" and in Welsh it's "Beth".
There are some other common sound
differences too. For example, words
beginning with "s" followed by "e" or "i",
which make a /ʃ/ sound in the Goedelic
languages, often begin with "h" in
the Brythonic languages. So the word for
old in Irish is "sean" and in Welsh its "hen".
Despite their coexistence with English
over the centuries, the Celtic languages
are very distinct from English. And
they're an important part of the history
and the culture and identity of the
United Kingdom and of Ireland, as well as
Brittany in France. But today most of the
Celtic languages are considered to be
endangered. With the English language and
French dominating, whether the Celtic
languages survive or not depends on the
communities to which they are native. And
that brings me to the Question of the
Day. For people from a community where a
Celtic language has traditionally been
spoken:
Do you speak a Celtic language? Do you
speak that language outside of school?
How valuable do you think it is to be
able to speak that language?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Be sure to follow Langfocus on
Facebook, Twitter, and Instagram, and once
again I'd like to say thank you to my
Patreon supporters, especially these ones
right here, for their monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.